what's up everybody welcome to stick to
football live if you're watching in the
BR app and hopefully you are we have an
exciting show for you today it is
redraft week here at bleach reports so
we're gonna give you some insider
stories from over the years of pics that
almost happen and didn't we also have
our great friend Dana Holgorsen one of
the realest coaches at college football
you're gonna join us for a little bit of
an interview Matt Melo and Connor of
course Connors hair is so tall it's
almost out of the shot now I have the
opposite problem and also we're gonna
take your draft on draft questions you
could leave a comment right here in the
app stream if you're watching the show
and we'll get to those at the end here
so a great way to interact with this
guys and my favorite thing about stick
to football we're not gonna tease
breaking news for 24 hours and then give
you something that you probably already
knew we're just gonna give it to you
straight right off the top yeah I mean
24 hours I waited I hate to make
somebody stay up kind of late at night
to watch some breaking news that wasn't
very breaking or exciting or even really
his news to talk about right it's
amazing
please don't hurt me yeah I was gonna
say we were talking about before we were
on air about people we would not want to
fight and the person that had this news
is definitely on the list so I'm gonna
stop right there well you know what
world quarantine Jay Glazer cannot beat
me up in the media he's at the top of
the list Oh without a doubt
nude republic he's still yet at the top
media remember if I was gonna fight one
it would probably be interesting silly I
know cuz he's tiny I'm not very big he's
pocket-sized all right we're not gonna
fight anyone though don't forget follows
in the Bleacher Report app if I'm just
at NFL Draft scale at Connor
somehow he's still that handle and at
Mello double-oh-seven he's apparently a
British secret agent but it is redraft
week and we have had a lot of fun we
redrafted some superstars in the show
like yesterday all week you've seen the
Jersey swaps the cool what might have
been Mike Tanner had a great remark
draft article but we're gonna tell you
some of our own stories from on the road
that we've heard where teams almost made
a pick or wanted to make a pick and
didn't get a chance to and it seems like
this one is just going to upset so many
people but I will start here guys
one story that you hear coming out of
the 2017 Draft and I believe this is
somewhat well-known now obviously the
morning of the draft the Kansas City
Chiefs trade up to the number ten
overall selection and they start leaking
to everyone in the media and we want a
linebacker we're gonna take a linebacker
not a quarterback we don't feel like
one's gonna be there so we're gonna take
a linebacker some of us like me put it
out on Twitter Chiefs traded up it
sounds like they want a linebacker
well they didn't they want a Patrick
mahomes the rest of the story is though
I'd like Paul Harvey and I just dated
myself Wow four people got that joke it
was that the Houston Texans were also
trying to do a similar move to trade up
to get Patrick mahomes they add him as
the number one quarterback on their
board deshaun Watson the number two
quarterback as as happens mahomes goes
ten Watson goes when I believe 12
overall once the Super Bowl winner one
is now stuck with maybe the clueless
most clueless general manager / head
coach I wonder if Watson was even the
number two quarterback on their board or
if they had watch this kid sling it
Mitchell Tripp this case key as they
call him in Chicago as a number two
quarterback on their board a lot of
people missed on Patrick mahomes though
I don't think we have to go too hard on
these teams to pass him over it could
happen to anybody it could even happen
to the best draft analysis in the world
it happens later they redeemed himself
yeah thank you yeah there is no doubt
about that this one would have been God
it would have been much interesting I
think if you're Patrick mahomes you are
very thankful each and every day that
you landed with Andy Reid and the Kansas
City Chiefs and I think for the Texans
at least at the end of the day it's not
like you got a bust you got a superstar
quarterback in deshaun Watson and one of
the throw backs that I want to tell you
guys about is about a trade that didn't
happen and sometimes you should be
thankful for those as well in the 2016
NFL Draft the Dallas Cowboys looking for
life after Tony Romo they take Zeke
Elliott in the top five they were
looking to get back into the first round
to draft Paxton Lynch and they could not
they called the New York Jets who were
picking at 20 the deal was on the table
the Jets were gonna get out of the first
round for a couple day two picks seeing
that they had a lot of needs and
did more ammo the Cowboys would gladly
come back up into the first round to get
the quarterback have that fifth-year
option and it was actually the New York
Jets that pulled the deal off the table
it was not Dallas so long story short
the Jets say no deal
Dallas ends up taking a guy named dak
Prescott in the fourth round of that
draft fellows
the Jets took Darren Lee at 20 I would
say that move did not work out for New
York that move changed what the future
looks like in Dallas well not only that
it look at what these teams did in the
second round that changed those
franchises completely because and the
Jets took Christian Hackenberg so this
completely changes I mean light in the
catenin probably you could go back to
this draft and say that's when the them
getting fired really started for the
Cowboys now they have such a solid
foundation with dak Zeke and Jalen Smith
as three of the leaders on this team so
go back to 2016 not great for your New
York Jets Connor Darren Lee I think he's
a chief now or was he from motion I
think he might not be anymore
and then Hackenberg was we saw him in
the the a AF well I think this is crazy
though cause like will give the Cowboys
credit for taking dak but I mean they
kind of missed on him too nobody
expected him to be this good but it
happens all the time in the NFL you'll
find a gym like a Tom Brady in the sixth
round and everybody else a who yay
Patriots you found the MVP at
quarterback but really like these guys
they passed him up too and Jerry I
remember him he loved Paxton Lynch
desperately wanted him was very angry
when he missed out on him it's crazy how
many people wanted Paxton Lynch that
year he was six-foot-seven guys play
small forward right that's what's
forgotten about we could sit here and
laugh a little it's like wow Dallas
really lucked out that the Jets walked
that deal you know but took it off the
table but there were a lot of teams that
wanted Paxton Lynch he still ends up
going in the first round and ends up
being a bus elsewhere while Dallas you
know we're waiting for them to get that
contract extension done but I would say
things worked out pretty well with dak
Prescott instead yeah it absolutely did
one more story that I've heard over the
road we'll go back again 2017 this was
such a loaded draft class to me I've
seen Miles Garrett at the top
- superstar quarterback Simon Holmes and
Watson but a player who I've spotlighted
this week Alvin Kamara a guy who I had
rated number 28 overall in that class he
failed to pick 67 there was a lot of
conversation about where does Kamara
come off the board he was kind of a
gadget player at Tennessee after getting
kicked out of Alabama goes to the
volunteers takes the job from Jalen Hurd
who's now a receiver for the San
Francisco 49ers and what Kamara it was
where does he come off the board and
into the 3rd round there was so much
posturing teams trying to get Kamara one
team the Jets wanted him badly the
Titans wanted him as well the Chiefs
were another team rumored to won Alvin
Kamara
none of those teams are able to get him
though because Sean Payton who I think
is one of the low key most connected men
in the NFL when it comes to rumors and
news Payton knew that all these other
teams wanted Kamara they trade up and
steal him from I mean think how
different the NFL is if the Chiefs take
Kamara instead of creme hunt or if the
Titans pair Derrick Henry with Alvin
Kamara or if the Jets like we're saying
sorry Jets fans we're not doing this
intentionally this was a bad year for
you guys if the Jets get in Alba Kamara
to go with now Sam darn old I mean these
franchises are completely different and
I think it goes to show how important
the draft is I mean you can pass on a
guy or if you miss out and you don't get
your guy it can set your franchise back
for years and for these GM's
it can cost you your job in a hurry and
something we always talk about guys that
plays into it yes this is player
evaluation it's grading players and
seeing who hits so much of it is draft
strategy and that's a perfect example
that story Matt I'm Sean Payton being a
guy that knows how to navigate up and
down the board getting Intel from other
teams figuring out what they're gonna do
and when you have to jump because
sometimes if it's too early you're gonna
give up more assets than you should have
but in this case for the Saints they did
not surrender a lot and they got one of
the best receiving backs in all the
football yeah and again it goes back to
it's somewhat draft strategy so a lot of
luck but I mean with the Saints your
Michael Thomas is another player who we
were gonna talk about this storm we have
a little bit time Michael Thomas is a
guy I was at the NFL Combine begging a
friend of mine who was high up in the
league at the time
hey draft Michael Thomas is my number
one receiver and he was like dude we
have a fifth round on that guy so
sometimes it's just it's good luck it's
bad luck and there are many
many misses to go along with the hits
like a Michael Thomas or an Alvin Kamara
so just a couple stories like I said
it's redraft week of bleach report if
you're in the app go to the NFL the NFL
Draft streams you're gonna see a ton of
content of pics that maybe should have
or should not have happened those are
always a ton of fun I love there you go
today's show is sponsored by the
upcoming PlayStation 5 the fine people
over at PlayStation wanted me to let all
the stickies know they're working hard
to get the new console in your living
room so don't get too bored staying at
home all the time
we know Madden the show and 2k are
filling the void real Sports left and
can't wait for everyone to enjoy their
favorite sports with Playstation 5s
high-powered graphics and brand new duel
sense controller add me on PlayStation
at NFL draft Scout challenged me to a
game of madden as soon as the draft is
over but just remember I call the Chiefs
with mahomes with my quarterback Melo
you can have all right let's check out
gridiron hide so we got a great recap of
the 2019 NFL draft from our favorite
cartoon I'm so excited for career day I
may look good BK
we're not a traditional workplace what
skills do you have
maybe we'll be in touch maybe we won't
it's all a big secret Sam Shelly the
Cardinals the Raiders are a great
organization and we're gonna burn it to
the ground man that's why great words so
just by looking at you I think you're
definitely Broncos quarterback material
sir that's a mom still I like that it's
[Music]
never mess with the Mannings on career
day we are joined today by the only
repeat coach ever on stick to football
and we got him when he just started his
job at Houston and now we get him a year
in a head coach Dana Holgorsen coach
they should take some time to hang out
with us this morning we appreciate it
yeah you got it guys that's much fun
doing it last year with you guys figured
I'd do it again plus we got a little
time on our hands right now so let's
let's let's talk something that
resembles yeah well let's jump in right
there then and talk football you have a
player in Josh Jones left tackle who's
projected to be a first round pick what
can you tell us about Josh from your
time when you got there Houston to where
he was when you last saw him I guess
yeah I couldn't be more proud of Josh
you know didn't didn't know him you know
my at my time at West Virginia we didn't
recruit Texas very much just based on
you know being an East Coast school and
had a unique way of doing things that
that turned out to be pretty successful
but so I didn't really know a whole lot
of guys on our team you know and
obviously Josh was one of them he was
one of the the main guys coming back so
he was one of the first ones that I
wanted to get to know pretty earlier you
know he's a he's an impressive guy now
and I'm really proud of the fact that
you know a couple of things that we
identified at Houston was
they didn't want kids didn't want a red
shirt and you know they they really
weren't interested and in graduation so
to speak so the two things that Josh did
he he did red shirt early you know he
decided to come back for his fifth year
there's a little bit of talking him
coming out early but he was a projected
six seventh round draft pick and and so
he hung in there and he came back for
his final year he got his degree which
I'm very proud of he worked on his craft
and he's he's he's worked himself into a
first round graphic and I think that is
gonna be an example that we use around
here for a long time to come
coach I feel like you're a guy who's
gonna shoot a straight how is he in the
locker room and character wife couldn't
be better
you know we had we had serial zero
issues with that whatsoever you know we
we had it we had a tough year lots been
made of it you know for a lot of reasons
you know we played six ranked teams I'm
here to tell you the American is pretty
dadgum good you know and you know this
is coming from a guy that's been in the
big 12 for 15 years or so so our
non-conference schedule was was
challenging we are the quality of
football that we had was really good we
just we you know we didn't you know we
had a lot of injuries and we had a lot
of red shirted kids a lot of ineligible
guys that that that we you know that we
that we know are gonna be valuable
players for us in the future and Josh
being one of the lone seniors that we
had on the team never complained one
time I put his head down he went to work
he got better every single game he was
he was on about a ten game stretch of
just showing improvement each and every
week you know and then game ten against
Central Florida he rolled his his ankle
up wasn't wasn't a serious issue but it
was serious enough for him not to play
in the last couple of games which has
supported he had done enough at that
point but first-round plays on there and
attitude was great on in there with what
the team the rest of the year could have
been more happy with what is his
performance was not only on the field
but just being in the locker room and
what kind of a person that he is
coach obviously a lot going on in the
world right now and I would have
imagined that really impacts not just
your day to day but the recruiting trail
what does that Bend like this last month
there's your day to day and how this it
really has affected your ability to
recruit well it's it's picked it up from
from from technology we I do what I'm
doing with you guys right now you know I
mean we do staff meetings like this we
do player meetings like this you know
I'm not gonna ignore my players you know
we got a lot of guys I'm gonna continue
to make sure that they're doing the
right thing every day and they're in
good spirits and their mental health is
is strong and they're excited about
coming back as soon as we're able to
come back from a recruiting perspective
you don't get the face-to-face in person
on campus stuff but but there's probably
more communication from a technology
perspective I stay on my phones with
them every day I get on zoom' meetings
with them we have offensive staff
meetings with specific individuals you
know I think we're ahead you know the
one thing about where we're at our staff
continuity was really good we've we've
been doing the same thing here for about
15 months now and our database is
obviously pretty good here in the city
of Houston so we're able to be in
contracting to guys they Leah it's just
it's just a different kind of recruiting
its face to face technology which we may
not like it as adults but the younger
generation certainly do like I was gonna
ask is that something you could see the
n-c-double-a maybe loosening the
standards all moving forward so there's
maybe not less face to face recruiting
as you said but maybe giving more
opportunity for zoom calls and FaceTime
and a more texting to where they've been
pretty strict on that in the past yeah
they've actually they've they've relaxed
those rules a little bit here recently
you know I remember back the day here
three four years ago you know you
couldn't text kids and you can only call
them once a week or whatever they've
relaxed that quite a bit you can text
them I meet all these social media
outlets that are available you can get
to them as easy as you want to I still
haven't called
prospect and probably about eight years
now we got in trouble a while ago as a
university as a whole I think there's
too many phone calls that were being
placed illegally I mean if you if you
call a person back and say yeah I missed
your call who is this I mean if it's a
recruit it could be a violation all
right so there's just if you add up all
the people that are in an athletic
department there's gonna be an
impermissible phone calls so I said
that's fine I'm never gonna make another
one so all I do is I text the guy call
me or I social media they're recruiting
sick call me and they're gonna call you
right away anyway so I just refused a
long another phone call for the rest of
my career right I like it that's genius
right there you're talking about
recruiting last year you hit the
transfer portal pretty hard this year
the transfer portal hits you pretty hard
though how much of that decision for
your team a lot of guys played those
four games and then they sat the rest of
the year was that something you guys sat
and talked about was that a player's
decision did your opinion come in on
that at all
well we've we've took advantage of the
the transfer portal for years I mean you
go back at the last four years that
we're at West Virginia where 50 percent
transfers and all those guys that were
drafted last year with you know will
Grier and Trayvon Westco and David sills
and guys like that those those were all
transfer guys but that was 50 percent of
our of our recruiting strategy there for
the last five years which is why we were
able to be able to compete from a talent
perspective I don't I don't think
Houston is any different we're gonna
keep the same strategy here we're gonna
get as many local high school kids in
this great city of Houston you know into
Louisiana East Texas up to Dallas but
it's very competitive here everybody's
recruiting down here you know so you
know guys want to leave they leave I'm
gonna work we're obviously only gonna
win a few of those battles but I tell
her guys be nice to them and keep
recruiting them because you never know
when they're gonna want to come back
home which means the transfer portal is
gonna be something that we look at daily
on there we got five spots on our board
still for the 2020 recruiting class that
we're gonna fill here in the next couple
of months with transfers I don't I don't
view you know
to this date you know we haven't lost
really anybody that we're really too
concerned with here going into the
transfer portal this year I think our
roster is incredibly healthy we're gonna
be right at eighty five scholarships
with a whole lot of guys that are
eligible and ready to make a difference
here this year then they couldn't
question coach we always loved being a
head on each draft class so we're
already thinking about not just next
week but next year and some of the
listeners of this show who are some of
the guys that we already get got to get
on our watch list that you're excited to
coach heading into next year yeah that's
that's a question that always gets me in
trouble you know if I look at my sheet
right here and I couple of guys on my
team are gonna be pissed that I didn't
name them you know so you know like I
said we didn't lose very many seniors
this year you know it's you know I had
four first rounders at West Virginia I
think Josh is gonna be the fifth one as
my head coach ten you're proud of that
you know and we got some guys coming
back we've got a lot of we got it next
year we're gonna have around 25 26
seniors on the team so we're gonna be a
lot older and we're gonna have some guys
with a lot of playing experience you
know I will mention to guys just because
these two guys are our our kids that are
that have been in the program for five
four four years going on fifth years
Marquess Stephenson is you know he's his
nickname speedy so you can imagine what
his greatest attribute is I mean dude
can just flat-out fly add more plays or
50 or more than anybody in the country
last year he's coming back for his fifth
year he was he was different in the
spring he reminded me of the the jump
that Tavon Austin made from his junior
year to his senior year you know just as
far as being a all-around player he's
got that kind of speed he's got that
kind of skill set and excited about what
he's gonna bring to the table as a fifth
year senior and then defensively Payton
Turner's a four year starter he's a 65
to 260 pound en that that maybe 270 I
mean but he looks the part he's got a
ton of snaps under
well those guys have the measurables you
know like I said we got 24 other guys
that have played a lot of ball that
that's it's gonna be fun to watch these
guys develop and now we got eight spring
practices in so we're a little ahead of
like most people are so it's fun to see
what their development is and once we
can get the green light to get back
started I know these guys are gonna be
eager to continue to improve to have a
expert twenty20 season coach as far as
getting that green light I don't know
about everybody else when we first got
quarantined for like two weeks all I did
was eat I didn't exercise I just like
ate every snack in the house Hill doing
them how do you make sure that these
like 18 to 22 year old kids are doing
their conditioning that they're eating
well and not just like that they're not
eating a bunch of junk food like I was
but that they're getting three meals a
day cuz not everyone you know comes from
a background where they have access to
that
how much monitoring are you guys able to
do of what the players are doing on a
day to day right now you know your your
your there's not there's nothing you
could do I mean we're in we're in
comport we're in communication with them
we call them every day the position
coaches call them every single day they
you know they check in academically you
know to our academic people every single
day if they don't check in that they get
a phone call immediately from a strength
and conditioning perspective from an
athletic training perspective there's
just not a whole lot you can do you can
call them and encourage them but that
that's about it we did a thing in spring
for eight days we you know we called it
what are you doing when no one's looking
and we just kind of video to person and
we said okay what you know are you you
know what are you doing during this
practice you you grab-assing and
screwing around the whole time are you
actually trying to get better you know
and so we called some people out on some
some of their behaviors when when they
thought nobody was looking and so I
remind them of that you know pretty much
once a week I just say look this is the
ultimate what are you doing when no
one's looking test because it really is
just not a whole lot that we can do
there's still NCAA rules and regulations
as far as what we can and can't do with
these guys and we just got to trust them
to put their best foot forward you know
and you know once were once we're able
to get back going we start our workouts
we're gonna probably figure out
didn't work out pretty pretty quickly
and then we can do something about it at
that point
yeah real quick I think you haven't
figured out in those first two days kind
of who who was working out who wasn't
coach predict what do you think the 2020
college football seasons gonna look for
like for us it's gonna be on time it's
gonna be a shortened season what are you
kind of thinking right now
you know what no matter what I say right
now it's gonna get criticized if I go
too early I'm gonna get criticized by
going right now you criticize I'm not
even gonna go there that's not a
decision that I'm gonna be a part of you
know administrators are gonna get on
committees and presidents and athletic
directors and conference commissioners
are gonna get together and they're gonna
I will say they'll follow the lead of
what the pro sports are gonna do you
know whatever NBA decides to do here
whatever major league baseball decides
to do then the NFL is gonna kind of get
together what are they gonna start doing
or they go small groups first OTAs push
everything back and just start
practicing before the season I don't
know whatever whatever those
professional organizations do is
probably what our our illustrious
administrators are gonna do and then
what do what we're told after that coach
last time we talked to you you just made
the jump you were you were leaving West
Virginia going to Houston and we know we
could tell how excited you were what are
some of the changes you noticed from
that 10 year gap from the last time you
were at Houston from when you just got
there now as the head coach
I take a while to explain everything
honestly I mean just you know our
presidents an absolute rockstar renuka
tour has been here for 12 years now
she's she's she's she's different you
know and she's turned down a bunch of
jobs and because she loves the city and
wants to stay at this university and
make it great enrollment has doubled you
know I think it was around 25,000 when I
was here 10 years ago it's a just under
50,000 now so you know we've moved into
Tier one that is academically there's
you know every athletic facility has
been redone from baseball to track and
field which track and field's the top
three four
around you know our coach sampson and
basketball has done a heck of a job top
ten team basketball wise and a brand new
forty two center which batman should
ring a bell to you
he's our Tillman's our our chair so he's
bringing a lot of knowledge and stuff to
the university as well it's completely
different things are being built our
endowment is as good as there is
anywhere so we're we're a healthy
University and and good things are just
gonna continue to happen for the
University of Houston
well coach we won't take up too much
more your time we know you're busy hub
we appreciate it
good luck to you guys this year and stay
safe man we're looking forward to seeing
well the Cougars look like a 2020
whenever you get back on the field
awesome thanks guys we are
[Music]
[Music]
good thing this is a two minute episode
see let's see ps4 starting at 1 hey put
on some cream thank Rus
what does here always say I'm only going
to stay in Seattle if you dress better
you guys are gonna believe this
I just not realize that I know us you're
awesome by watching that the 1 2 step
thing had no idea pretty good pretty
good Dana Holgorsen as well thanks to
coach for making some time with us on
the zoom call always a good time I do
regret we didn't get to kick back with
some sugar-free Red Bulls like we like
we normally do let's do some draft on
draft questions guys you guys have been
loading up the the comment stream here
with some questions so let's hop into it
our first question what position group
has the biggest drop off after the top
tier I actually I'm gonna go last on
this so normally I like old like a
kidney candy store and I want to jump in
steal the answers but I'm gonna pass
I'll say corner I think the quarterback
class after the top tier because the top
tier for me is it CUDA and then CJ
Henderson and then after that we're
gonna see a big gap about 20 pigs
probably before we see the next one go
and I like the corner class I think it's
a very deep class and you know the guys
that are sitting there on my board from
3 to 6 are good and could be Pro Bowlers
I think those top two guys act to be
very special though top in the NFL I
love this question because you can go a
lot of different directions I think the
runningback group we talked about the
top 5 whether it's Jonathan Taylor
DeAndre swift JK Dobbins Clyde Britt see
later on cam akers that group seems to
be lumped together
and then a little bit of a drop off
there the tight ends you have Cole
commit and then good luck with the rest
of it but I think my answer here guys is
gonna surprise you a little bit it might
be the quarterback class
I think when you're oh damn it and let's
you a ton of I lower I think it's a two
quarterback class and listen Jordan love
has great traits and we'll see if
someone can develop him in a good
situation you know Justin Herbert we've
been vocal on the show our concerns
about him those guys have tools after
that it's not looking great I really do
think it's the gap between Joe burrow
and tua or at least together and then
below them that that's the biggest
drop-off I didn't even listen to Melos
answer because I was thinking about what
I was gonna say about the quarterback so
this is what happens when I don't just
let myself go first and now I had to
think of one on the fly how about the
edge Club the edge rusher class because
chase young is top than Caleb on chase
on and then I think there's a decent
drop off to eat or gross Matos after
that big drop-off the guys like Josh
each a trail Louis you're rolling the
dice on some guys who are either small
or have a lot of injury concerns lesson
learned I will never go last again can I
put it on record though that like Jordan
loves gonna fall to the Saints and we're
all gonna look stupid because Saints
fans you guys hated him on record I
don't hate him with Sean Payton just
know I've already said like Monday after
the draft like Twitter will just be I
would like to change my ranking of this
player now that I know where he is
because that's the Green Bay yeah
exactly yeah Green Bay I don't think
it'll be New England but New England of
course the Saints are a really good one
even in Indy I'll say this if he falls
with the car and then it's up Indy
whether they come back in for him I
think that's a good staff for him it's
like Jacob Eason to the Buccaneers I
want to take back everything negative
I've said if he goes there did you learn
from Tom Brady and it's a perfect scheme
fit frame right second question guys
from Jackson Warren is there a chance
that Titans take a wide receiver in the
first round if not what corner do you
think they get at 29 so I think they go
corner or offensive tackle at 29
depending on who's available
I think receivers more like a second or
third round need for them especially
someone has some speed and could be a
playmaker so what corner could be there
to me
AJ Terrell from Clemson and Jalen
Johnson from Utah are exceptional scheme
fits for them good thing about Mike
Vrabel let's think about a New England
type corner you want someone with some
size physicality at the line of
scrimmage like Malcolm Butler who they
have like Stephon Gilmore I know Jeff
glad knees a hot name around that range
of 29 overall I don't know he's a little
small he's sticky at the line of
scrimmage he's a little small for their
scheme you just kind of got that dog and
even though that mic variables gonna
like so I think that makes up for some
of the size will they take a receiver in
the first round I don't think so because
I don't think they want one of these
guys with size if they do maybe Brandon
IU cuz that change of pace receiver that
can come play in a slot and be exciting
but I agree with you I think it's gonna
be a corner there's just so much depth
there and you know the offensive tackles
maybe they take a chance on a guy like
Isaiah Wilson I think he fits and he can
shine right into right tackle and be a
starter for them but I don't know that
might be a little bit rich for Isaiah
Wilson still I was gonna say that seems
like the Dark Horse pick when you look
at a plug and play kind of right tackle
now I say a Wilson has his limits
you know his deficiencies and pass
protection but we know how much that
team likes to just run the football over
and over again
nyaaa Wilson is a guy that can
definitely run block we know that so
maybe they're at 29 they think about
taking him because we've heard it the
range for him is all over the place
you're not gonna have the chance to come
back and get him in the second round or
anything like that when you look at
corners Matt I love that you bring up
you know what what is this team looking
for it is it an outside guy that has the
length that is 6 1 and then maybe you
kick a Dori Jackson on the inside or are
they comfortable because of his talent
taking Jeff Gladney and saying listen we
think Gladney could play on the outside
for us or we can flip him in a Dori
around in the slot give us a lot of
versatility on this defense I think I'm
gonna learn a lot about Tennessee in
this draft at cornerback
all right burns to Damas not going Oscar
Thomas but I'm with you here burn he has
money on Judy to be drafted 13 or later
Anne drugs to be drafted 13 year later
he wants to know how we feel about it
well burn buddy I feel a lot worse about
it right now than I did yesterday
because I would have said that's
possible but now there's some rumors
Michael Lombardi I think is from the
athletic putting it out there maybe that
the Broncos trying to trade up to number
10 the Browns turn
trade back to 15 if the Broncos trade up
to ten we could see CD lamb or Jerry
Judy come off the board there we've
talked about how one of those guys might
already go at 9:00 to Jacksonville and
then you have the Jets and the Raiders
at 11 and 12 I don't I don't feel as
good about your money right now I don't
feel great about it either I think when
you look at this draft we always say at
time is a flat circle we're starting to
come back around on the receiver so we
have a slot at 11 12 13 sorry about your
Niners map because people are moving up
in front of them now where I think we
could see our three receivers ago nine
ten with a trade Denver coming up to
Cleveland spot nine ten 11 where they go
in a row in the Raiders and the Niners
gonna be sitting there thinking Hammond
we should have kind of receiver earlier
they might have to make those money
moves again if crit CJ Henderson is
there 13 I'm gonna be okay though
but if Henderson and the receivers are
gone and they take Javon Kinlaw counter
I'm calling it now I will bring
something on set I will throw this stick
to football helmet at my camera if they
think Javon Kinlaw 13 overall that are
very bull yeah around us we just
brunching back item yes exactly and I
think when you look at this 100 per cell
per I'll break my camera or probably on
that one but I mean here in New Jersey
you can just bet online I've been
looking at all these odds I would like
to know what the odds were here for
versus Adamas because man those are some
risky bets guys I feel better about
Jerry Judy making it to 13 actually now
than his teammate Henry rugs
I don't think rugs is there at 13 I
think it's a reason we've heard so much
buzz about the Broncos being one of the
trade up teams them in Atlanta you hear
it over and over again
I think rugs if it's starting to feel
like guys that his floor is Vegas at 12
and if you said that five months ago
people would look at you like you're
crazy
but I think for Henry rugs it feels once
again like his floor is 12 and a ceiling
of even maybe even seven if the Panthers
move out of that pick for someone else
depending what the cost is I'd like to
know how you guys feel the receiver is
where they're their pick floors stand
right now
yeah I would have said 15 close the
floor for the third receiver but and
I've had my heart set on for like a week
Henry drugs going to the Niners like
I've just been something a vision board
I've been thinking about it like I'm
seeing it what I'm I just don't think he
gets past the Raiders I was like the war
now I think it has moved to 13 I think
that would probably see a move with
Denver you know our guy Thomas - Mitch -
Atlanta thinks he wants to move up
he really likes those Alabama receivers
so you're gonna add a third one to his
roster this year oh my god alright well
that is our show I'm gonna be depressed
now thank you guys very much
hey don't forget to check out Bleacher
Report's live coverage of the NFL Draft
rounds one through five right here in
the Bleacher Report app dreaming every
night Adam left co-hosting the damn
thing myself and counter breaking down
teams and picks Melo is gonna be
dominating it on social media so make
sure to follow all of us on Twitter I'm
at and if they'll draft Scott he's at
Melo and he is at Connor Jay Rogers
don't forget you can listen to the show
wherever you get your podcast or
continue to find us right here in the
Bleacher Report app we'll be back Monday
5 o'clock Eastern Time getting you all
ready for the 2020 draft only a week
away can't wait one week